ich habe dich willkommen an den
geschenken geschäftsführung
bundesgesundheitsminister jens spahn an
professor dr lothar wieler dem präsident
des robert koch instituts und professor
dr sander der leiter der
forschungsgruppe für infektions
immunologie und impfstoffforschung an
der berliner charité wir sprechen heute
über die aktuelle lage und vor allem den
fokus auf die auffrischimpfungen gegen
kurbelt 19 und ehe wir inhaltlich
beginnen noch kurz ein paar sätze zu
unserer organisation angesichts der
tatsache dass wir heute einen livestream
haben und man nicht voraussetzen kann
dass jeder diese einrichtung kennt die
bundespressekonferenz ist
regierungsunabhängig eine
selbstorganisation von journalistinnen
und journalisten die in berlin oder bonn
aber maßen sich in berlin über
bundespolitik berichten und hier an
dieser stelle pressekonferenzen
organisieren fragen stellen können und
diese in aller regel auch beantwortet
bekommen so wird das hoffentlich heute
auch der fall sein und da bin ich guter
dinge wir begrenzen das ganze auf eine
stunde und halten es mit der bewährten
regel jeder kollege jede kollegin hat
eine frage gegebenenfalls eine nachfrage
und sollte dass die zeit erlauben nehme
ich sie wieder auf die liste wenn es
weitere frage bedarf gibt soviel der
vorrede und dann starten wir herr
schwarz ja liebe frau wolff meine damen
und herren das auslaufen der dänischen
lager als rechtlicher zustand ist von
vielen als zeichen missverstanden worden
die pandemie wäre vorbei wenn auch
äußerungen von mir so verstanden werden
konnten dann war ich nicht klar genug
das sage ich auch selbstkritisch denn
das ist nicht der fall die pandemie ist
alles andere als vorbei und darauf
möchten wir eben hier auch ein weiteres
mal ausdrücklich hinweisen denn wir
verlassen zwar ein rechtlichen
ausnahmezustand und bringen das
verhältnis von regierung und parlament
wieder in den rechtlichen normalmodus
aber die pandemie
ist offenkundig nicht nur weiterhin da
sondern die vierte welle ist es mit
voller wucht es braucht daher weiterhin
ein zustand der besonderen vorsicht auf
einen zustand mit staatlichen
schutzmaßnahmen und es braucht eben vor
allem auch die eigenverantwortung die
vorsicht jedes einzelnen denn jeder von
uns hat ja die instrumente die es
braucht sozusagen für sich auch in der
hand um den entscheidenden unterschied
zu machen impfen testen aha regeln
schutzmasken tragen insbesondere im
öffentlichen raum im öffentlichen
nahverkehr im einzelhandel all das sind
auch weiterhin die wege um den
entscheidenden unterschied jetzt zu
machen wir erleben gerade vor allem eine
pandemie der ungeimpften und die ist
massiv die infektionszahlen steigen die
zahl der korona toten mit ihnen und auch
vor allem die zahl der intensiv
flüchtigen patientinnen und patienten in
einigen regionen in deutschland im
übrigen regionen wo auch die impfquoten
teilweise nicht so hoch sind wie in
anderen regionen einigen regionen in
deutschland werden die intensivbetten
wieder knapp über verlegung in andere
regionen wird nachgedacht sie werden
konkret geplant zur wahrheit gehört im
übrigen auch auf den intensivstationen
würden deutlich weniger coop 19
patienten liegen und behandelt werden
müssten wenn alle die es könnten sich
auch impfen lassen würden ich verstehe
daher den frust vieler pflegekräfte sehr
sehr gut die sich eben angesichts dieser
belastung die sie in ihrem alltag
dadurch haben schon die frage stellen
warum denn nicht mehr sich impfen lassen
das weiß ich aus vielen gesprächen die
herausforderung ist das zeigt ja auch
eine von uns veröffentlichte
forsa-umfrage dass diejenigen die sich
bisher nicht impfen haben lassen ist
jedenfalls in der übergroßen zahl auch
nicht tun wollen kaum zu überzeugen sind
dass eine situation mit der wir umgehen
müssen wo es jetzt darum geht für herbst
und winter
insgesamt für den einzelnen zum schutz
des einzelnen aber eben auch vor allem
für die vermeidung der überlastung der
belastung des gesundheitswesens einen
unterschied zu machen dafür braucht es
aus meiner sicht drei punkte von denen
ich mir auch wünsche dass bund und
länder sie gemeinsam mit nachdruck
unterstützen das erste sind die
beschlossenen vorsichtsmaßnahmen 3g und
aha regeln konsequent umzusetzen und im
übrigen wo nötig auch durch zweig zu
ergänzen das zweite sind verpflichtende
test konzepte für die pflegeheime wie
durch die orte an denen die besonders
verwundbaren leben und das gilt eben
auch mit verpflichtenden testungen für
auch geimpftes oder gelesenes personal
und besucherinnen und besucher und zum
dritten geht es um viele viele
auffrischimpfungen zum ersten zu 3g da
wohl 3g gilt also gebens genesen oder
getestet in öffentlichen rest in
öffentlichen einrichtungen restaurants
museen in unterschiedlichsten bereichen
möchte ich wirklich mit nachdruck dafür
werben es tatsächlich auch zu
kontrollieren ich erlebe es zu oft auch
selbst dass gesagt wird wir glauben
ihnen schon schon okay ich freue mich
über dieses vertrauen aber ich finde wir
brauchen dort wirklich mehr und
konsequenteres kontrollieren im übrigen
dann auch ein kontrollieren der behörde
wenn vor ort einfach mal konsequent ein
paar tage lang in restaurants in
öffentlichen einrichtungen das
kontrollieren kontrolliert wird
gegebenenfalls mit bußgeldern bin ich
sehr sicher das signal kommt auch sehr
schnell an wir sehen in ländern wie
italien
ich habe selbst würden g20 treffen in
rom erlebt wenn ich an einem tag öfter
in rom kontrolliert werden nach meinem
ausweis als in deutschland manchmal in
vier wochen dann finde ich geht da noch
mehr darum möchte ich ausdrücklich
werben und dazu gehört zum zweiten auch
zweig in regionen als weitere stufe die
eben eine besondere belastung haben ist
beziehungsweise war eine besondere
belastung droht ich will darauf
hinweisen dass wir das seitens des
bundesministeriums für gesundheit wie
auch das robert koch institut bereits im
august gefordert haben diese option
zweig in solchen regionen mit denn auch
die beschlüsse aufzunehmen und
vorzusehen dass es damals nicht erfolgt
ich wäre sehr dafür dass das jetzt
geschieht gesehen ja da bin ich auch dem
sächsischen ministerpräsidenten sehr
dankbar für die klarheit an dieser
stelle wir sehen ja dass das eben dann
in bestimmten regionen auch notwendig
ist um ein unterschied zu machen das hat
im übrigen nichts mit impf mobbing zu
tun sondern es geht darum das sehen wir
etwa in sachsen und thüringen eine
überlastung des gesundheitswesens zu
vermeiden das ist der entscheidende
punkt zweitens zu den test konzepten die
die todesnachrichten aus einer
seniorenresidenz in brandenburg aber aus
anderen haben uns eher nord erneut vor
augen geführt wie wichtig dort weiterhin
verpflichtende tests konzepte sind ich
sage noch einmal das gilt unabhängig vom
status denn gerade in diesen bereichen
wo es die besonders verwundbare
ihre wohnung haben ihr leben leben
gerade in diesen bereichen ist es ihm
sehr wichtig dass diejenigen die ein und
ausgehen dass ist das personal und das
sind die besucherinnen und besucher
nicht das virus selbst wenn sie geimpft
sein sollten in die einrichtung
hineintragen ich werde sehr dafür werben
bei der gesundheitsministerkonferenz
morgen und übermorgen bei den
kolleginnen und kollegen dass wir diese
verpflichtenden test um die einige
länder schon haben aber eben nicht alle
auch in ganz deutschland haben ich
möchte das sterben in dem pflegeheim
nicht noch einmal erleben müssen wie im
letzten winter
und dafür sind dritter punkt auch die
auffrischimpfung sehr sehr wichtig und
auch da will ich mal vielleicht eines
noch erinnern
die ersten beschlüsse
zur auffrischimpfung von bund und
ländern in der
gesundheitsministerkonferenz gab es
anfang august
das ist drei monate her wir haben anfang
august miteinander vereinbart dass in
einem ersten schritt alle bewohnerinnen
und bewohner in den pflegeeinrichtungen
das personal ein drittes mal ein
impfangebot bekommen sollen und wenige
zeit danach miteinander vereinbart
vorsorglich alle über 60 jährigen in
deutschland ein entsprechendes empfang
gebot zu machen es ist jetzt drei monate
her und in diesen drei monaten hat es
bis heute nur gut zwei millionen
auffrischimpfungen in deutschland
gegeben dass es zu wenig das ist
deutlich zu wenig das möchte ich auch
klipp und klar sagen das tempo beim
boostern reicht nicht und deswegen muss
man auch sagen alle pflegeheime sollten
nach diesen drei monaten eigentlich
schon ein drittes mal eben auch
aufgesucht worden sein durch mobile
teams um eine auffrischimpfung
anzubieten in vielen ländern ist das
passiert aber noch nicht in allen es
gibt zudem länder wie
nordrhein-westfalen oder berlin die
schreiben auch alle älteren an um sie
aktiv wie bei der erstimpfung einzuladen
und zu in formieren über die dritte
impfung dass die sinn macht man sieht
doch bitte in anspruch nimmt ich wäre
sehr dafür dass es diese schriftliche
information in allen bundesländern für
diejenigen altersgruppen gibt für dieses
besonderen sinn macht zudem möchte ich
morgen in einer gesprächsrunde mit
vertreterinnen und vertretern von
ärzteverbänden
auch das nochmal miteinander diskutieren
ein gemeinsames schreiben auch an die
erste schafft machen wenn zu viele
impfwillige finden aktuell kein arzt der
sie impft das ist das was uns täglich
berichtet wird auch dort finde ich
müssen wir gemeinsam mit der ärzteschaft
zu einem auflösen kommen und deshalb
möchte ich auch gerne dass die länder
ihre öffentlichen impf angebote wieder
auf und ausbauen das müssen nicht die
zentralen großen impfzentren sein
es können auch natürlich dezentralere
kleinere anlaufstellen seien wichtig ist
aber dieses öffentliche angebot noch da
will ich darauf hinweisen am 28 juni
haben wir in der
gesundheitsministerkonferenz miteinander
vereinbart punkt 2 a in dem beschluss
dass eben diese öffentlichen angebote in
den standby betrieb gehen und bei bedarf
zügig wieder hochgefahren werden können
und diesen bedarf sehen wir eben aktuell
wenn es um die auffrischimpfungen geht
und natürlich werden wir auch weiterhin
bei social media über anzeigen aber auch
verstärkt mit radio und tv spots für
diese auffrischimpfung werden denn die
auffrischimpfungen helfen die vierte
welle zu brechen ich meine das ist jetzt
nur ein ein bild aus israel wo man
einfach sehr sehr deutlich sieht mit den
auffrischimpfungen es ist gelungen die
kurven nach unten zu bringen und der
israelische gesundheitsminister war mit
einer delegation letzte woche in berlin
er war auch beim robert-koch-institut
ich glaube sogar ziemlich lange gab es
einen sehr intensiven austausch dort
auch mit ihnen mich ausgetauscht man
sieht einfach am beispiel israel dass
das boostern tatsächlich einen echten
unterschied macht in ganz vielen
aspekten und deswegen möchte ich eben
auch mit den kolleginnen und kollegen
den ländern darüber reden wie wir das
was grundsätzlich möglich ist die
zulassung dafür gibt es ja nämlich allen
die wollen jenseits der jähnigen für die
es empfohlen ist auch für alle die
wollen nach sechs monaten eine
auffrischimpfung möglich zu machen das
ist so ähnlich über den kinderimpfungen
es gibt eine ausdrückliche empfehlung
durch die ständige impfkommission und
für alle anderen ist es aber möglich
weil die zulassung auch da ist und dass
eben tatsächlich dann auch möglich zu
machen durch faktische impfmöglichkeiten
darüber darum geht es im stoff genug
jedenfalls ist dafür da über diese wenn
sie so wollen drei punkte plan sprechen
wir auf der gesundheitsministerkonferenz
morgen und übermorgen
trotzdem halte ich es für wichtig dass
neben den gesundheitsministerin und
gesundheitsministern wir auch
politisch und in der sache die
ministerpräsidentin und
ministerpräsidenten mit ins boot nehmen
gerade weil wir uns innerhalb zeit des
übergangs m befinden mit einer noch
geschäftsführend im amt befindlichen
regierung und einer neuen die sich
gerade parallel bildet finde ich ist
sehr sehr wichtig dass wir
entscheidungen in dieser pandemie auf
eine möglichst breite basis stellen wir
sehen übrigens auch in dem moment wo auf
ministerpräsidenten konferenzen im bund
länder gesprächen eine große
einheitlichkeit entsteht im tun und in
der kommunikation entsteht auch
akzeptanz die führt zur
verhaltensänderung die führt zu größerer
vorsicht
und genau das brauchen wir jetzt
[Musik]
ja und meine damen und herren die sieben
tage intelligenz ist sprunghaft
angestiegen es werden wieder deutlich
mehr menschen mit 19 im krankenhaus
behandelt und es liegen auch wieder
deutlich mehr patienten auf
intensivstationen und die tendenz ist
weiter steigend kleider sehen sie auch
wieder mehr todesfälle an einigen tagen
werden wieder mehr als 100 tote dem
robert koch institut übermittelt das
sind erschreckende zahlen die vierte
welle entwickelt sich leider genauso wie
wir es befürchtet hatten weil nicht
genug menschen geimpft sind und weil
maßnahmen wie die asl regeln sowie die
2g und 3g regeln nicht mehr ausreichend
umgesetzt werden ich möchte noch mal
ganz klar sagen für ungeimpfte ist das
risiko hoch dass sie sich in den
nächsten monaten infizieren dass einige
von ihnen schwer krank werden und auch
dass sie andere anstecken es werden sich
leider auch immer mehr geimpfte
anstecken und erkrankten die impfung
wirkt nicht immer bei allen geimpften
gleich außerdem kann der impfschutz im
laufe der zeit nachlassen besonders bei
älteren die ohnehin sehr gefährdet sind
wenn wir jetzt nicht gegensteuern wie
diese vierte welle wieder viel leid
bringen es werden viele menschen schwer
erkranken und sterben und das
gesundheitswesen wird wieder stark
belastet wir wissen wie wir das virus
eindämmen können wir haben alle
werkzeuge in der hand das robert koch
institut empfiehlt schon seit letztem
jahr die umsetzung der komik der
kontroll kowitz strategie wie dem wir
die pandemie ein erstens durch impfungen
zweitens brauchen wir gleichzeitig
weiterhin noch allgemeine
infektionsschutz maßnahmen zunächst ein
paar worte zum impfen ziel der
impfkampagne ist vor allem möglichst
viele schwere cupid 19 fälle und
todesfälle zu verhindern
lassen sie sich jetzt impfen die
allermeisten geimpften sind sehr gut
vorerkrankungen vor allem vor schweren
verläufen geschützt das sieht man ganz
deutlich wenn man die instanzen von
geimpften und ungeimpften miteinander
vergleicht geimpfte erkranken viel
seltener an co at 19 und sie müssen auch
viel seltener als krankenhaus trotzdem
sind in deutschland noch 16,2 millionen
menschen im alter über zwölf jahre nicht
geimpft darunter sind sogar noch 3,2
millionen schulden doch 3,2 millionen
menschen die über 60 jahre sind und die
sind ja bekanntlich besonders gefährdet
also ich kann nur noch mal operieren
bitte lassen sie sich jetzt impfen es
gibt keinen grund das nicht zu tun denn
die impfstoffe sind sicher und sie sind
wirksam
wenn eine auffrischungsimpfung für sie
empfohlen ist daneben sie diese bitte
war damit sie bestmöglich geschützt sind
die stiko empfiehlt eine
auffrischungsimpfung derzeit vor allem
für menschen über 70 und medizinisches
personal
die auffrischungsimpfung sollte sechs
monate nach der ersten serie stattfinden
und alle auch die jüngeren die eimer mit
jansen geimpft wurden also mit johnson
johnson sollten ihren impfschutz
optimieren und sich ein zweites mal mit
einem mr impfstoff impfen lassen aber
impfungen sind keine wunderwaffe sie
würden nicht immer bei allen geimpften
der impfschutz kann eben nach einiger
zeit nachlassen und geimpfte erkrankte
können dass wir es auch weiter geben
deshalb brauchen wir zusätzlich noch die
bewährten generellen maßnahme ich bitte
sie deshalb auch die geimpft und die
chinesen in diesem winter weiter die asl
regeln einzuhalten abstand halten um
mögliche jene regeln beachten eine
medizinische maske tragen besonders in
allen räumen und den bussen und bahnen
und natürlich in innenräumen auch
regelmäßig lüften
verzichten sie auf kontakte die nicht
unbedingt notwendig sind vor allem wenn
viele menschen gleichzeitig in
innenräumen zusammenkommen und wenn die
symptome einer akuten atemwegsinfektion
haben bleiben sie bitte unbedingt zu
hause und lassen sich testen die
maßnahmen müssen an die jeweilige
situation angepasst werden das ergibt ja
schon dafür seit langem empfehlungen in
der control kowitz strategie raus zu
diesen maßnahmen gehören auch 2g und 3g
regelungen durch sie haben wir ein hohes
maß an normalität in unserem land wieder
erlangen viele können wieder halbwegs
sicher ins restaurant oder zur
veranstaltung gehen 2g
bedeutet dass nur geimpfte und chinesen
an einer veranstaltung teilnehmen dürfen
3g bedeutet dass geimpfte genesene und
frisch negativ getestete an der
veranstaltung teilnehmen dürfen dadurch
reduziert sich die wahrscheinlichkeit
einer ansteckung sehr deutlich bei 2
gehen natürlich noch deutlicher als bei
3g aber um diese sicherheit zu
gewährleisten meine damen und herren ist
es natürlich ganz entscheidend dass der
im status der genesenen status oder die
testergebnisse auch belegt und überprüft
werden das geht auch ganz einfach mit
der korona web oder der koffer sap damit
kann man im chart ifi karrte genesenen
nachweise und testergebnisse digital
ablegen und bei bedarf vorzeigen
ganz wichtig ist dass die veranstalter
beim einlass mit der kopf postchef
prüfen ob die zertifikate echt sind und
ob sie auch zur jeweiligen person gehört
diese apps wurden gemeinsam von sap
telekom ibm mit dem robert koch institut
entwickelt und sie stehen jedem
kostenfrei zur verfügung und ganz
wichtig die arm und l regeln sollen auch
bei 2g oder 3g veranstaltung beachtet
werden auch geimpfte genesene und
getestete dürfen sich nicht in falscher
sicherheit wiegen also zusammenfassend
wir alle wollen dass dieser winter der
letzte winter der kogit 19 pandemie sein
wird wir alle schätzen unsere freiheit
aber lassen sie uns weiterhin mit dieser
freiheit
verantwortungsvoll umgeht freiheit ist
viel mehr als nur die individuelle wahl
von kogit 19 maßnahmen die wahl nicht
selbst zu schützen klar aber vielmehr
auch die wahl die eigenen wünsche
zurückzustellen um das allgemeinwohl zu
erreichen solidarität
bleibt das gebot der stunde
alle karten liegen auf dem tisch lasst
sie uns doch einfach spielen impfen
lassen auffrischungen waren im masken
tragen basis maßnahmen einhalten 2g 3g
ich bitte wirklich jeden einzelnen von
ihnen eindringlich diese maßnahmen
umzusetzen und mitzutragen wir haben es
jetzt zum größten teil selbst in der
hand wie sich der virtuelle entwickeln
wird für alle tragen die verantwortung
dafür gemeinsam wenn sich möglichst
viele menschen impfen lassen und wir
alle maßnahmen konsequent anwenden dann
können wir viele schwere erkrankungen
verhindern und dann werden wir auch
viele menschenleben retten
vielen dank auch dafür und dann bin ich
bei professor sander
guten tag meine damen und herren
sie haben schon von meinen vorrednern
reserve und der minister sparen gehört
nicht zu erwarten war steigen jetzt in
der kalten jahreszeit leider muss man
sagen die inzidenz wieder stark und in
der folge eben auch die belegungszahlen
in den krankenhäusern und auf den
intensivstationen
hinzu kommt dieses jahr aber auch das
muss man auch klar sagen dass wir
weniger intensiv kapazitäten zur
verfügung haben weil durch die enormen
belastungen in den vorangegangen
infektionswellen einfach auch
pflegepersonal regelrecht weggebrochen
ist und aus eigener erfahrung kann ich
ihnen berichten dass auch auf die
normalstation die lage zunehmend
angespannter wird und auch dort die
belastung für das personal gemens sind
im unterschied zum letzten herbst und
das wurde jetzt auch schon mehrfach
gesagt haben wir aber glücklicherweise
hocheffektive impfstoffe gegen diese
gefährliche erkrankung und seit
spätestens mitte letzten jahres stehen
die sie ja auch wirklich jedem in
deutschland jedem erwachsenen in
deutschland zur verfügung die in europa
zugelassenen impfstoffe sind extrem
sicher sie wurden mittlerweile weltweit
milliarden fach eingesetzt und es gibt
sehr große studien die millionen von
datensätzen ausgewertet haben und die
insbesondere für die mrn ahlen stoffe
eine herausragende wirksamkeit und eine
extrem hohe sicherheit bescheinigen die
impfstoffe schützen sehr effektiv vor
einer schweren ko mit 19 erkrankung umso
bedauerlicher ist es daher dass ein
weiterhin zu großer teil und herr villa
hat ihm die zahlen gerade genannt in
unserer bevölkerung bislang diese in
form nicht in anspruch genommen hat
es ist völlig klar dass die belastung in
den krankenhäusern auf der
intensivstation
sehr eng mit der zahl der ungeimpften
menschen verknüpft ist in den hoch
gefährdeten risikogruppen sind insgesamt
noch zu wenig menschen gm gehört 3,2
millionen menschen über 60 aber auch
andere gruppen wie zum beispiel
schwangere da sind immer noch zu wenig
menschen geimpft und wir sehen dass auf
unseren stationen leider
die häufig geäußerten sorgen um mögliche
langzeitfolgen sind unbegründet
zumal ihnen das sehr reale risiko von 19
und den bekannten komplikationen
gegenüberstehen deswegen kann ich genau
wie meine vorredner auch nur dringend
appellieren die impfung wahrzunehmen und
auch sagt es der behandelnden ärztinnen
und ärzte in diese angebote immer wieder
zu erneuern und auch auf die patienten
zuzugehen
zudem schützt eine impfung aber auch
über die eigene gesundheit hinaus unsere
mitmenschen und ich sage das bewusst
ganz deutlich weil das immer wieder auch
in frage gestellt wird zwar können auch
geimpfte personen sich anstecken und sie
können auch das virus weiter geben das
ist mittlerweile auch gut bekannt dazu
gibt es studien und es wird ja auch
medial immer wieder vier berichtet
fakt ist jedoch dass die
wahrscheinlichkeit sich anzustecken wenn
man geimpft ist deutlich geringer ist
als wir mal um geimpft ist und auch die
wahrscheinlichkeit einer virus
weitergabe einer transmission ist
geringer wenn also nur geimpfte oder
genesene zusammenkommen ist einfach das
risiko der verbreitung der infektion
geringer umso wichtiger ist es daher
dass mitarbeitende im gesundheits und
bildungswesen und in
gemeinschaftseinrichtungen sich impfen
lassen und dadurch sich und andere
schützen
klar ist und auch das ist durchgekommen
die impfung bietet keinen
hundertprozentigen schutz und den gibt
es im übrigen glaube ich auch bei keiner
mir bekannten medizinischen maßnahme die
verbreitung der deutlich ansteckenden
delta variante hat die parameter der
pandemie auch noch mal ein bisschen
verändert sie verbreitet sich schneller
und auch der impfschutz ist etwas
geringer im vergleich zum ursprünglichen
wildtyp gegen den die impfstoffe
entwickelt wurden nichtsdestotrotz und
das muss man auch betonen bleibt die
schutzwirkung der mhm stoffe auch gegen
die delta variante sehr sehr hoch das
zeigen große studien aus den usa aus
england und aus israel und im übrigen
auch die daten des robert koch instituts
insbesondere schutz vor einer schweren
ko mit 19 erkrankungen ist bei
vollständiger impfung weitergegeben
allerdings und jetzt kommen wir zu den
booster impfung muss man auch festhalten
dass die schutzwirkung nach zweimaliger
impfung so circa fünf bis sechs monate
nach abschluss der in serie wieder
abnimmt das ist aus ökologischer sicht
vollkommen erwartbar wenn sie eine akute
immunreaktion zum beispiel auf eine
impfung haben dann dann fällt diese
immunität auf ein gewisses basis level
wieder ab und das ist dass es erwartbar
und bei erregern die sich beispielsweise
über die blutbahn oder die lymphe
verbreiten ist auch dieses basisniveau
in der regel vollkommen ausreichend da
war die korona wehren sich lokal in der
schleimhaut der atemwege vermehren und
von dort aus weiter gegeben werden ist
es logisch auch schwerer oder
schwieriger einen kompletten schutz
aufrecht zu erhalten deswegen sehen wir
hier mit der zeit etwas häufiger
sogenannte durchbruch infektionen
insbesondere bei den älteren menschen
deren immunsystem ohnehin schwächer auf
impfungen reagiert das wissen wir von
einem anderen impfungen auch nimmt aber
dieser impfschutz nach einigen monaten
noch deutlicher ab
in unseren eigenen studien konnten wir
zeigen dass ungefähr 40 prozent der
menschen über 70 jahre ungefähr sechs
monate nach ihrer impfung keine
neutralisierenden antikörper gegen die
data variante mehr haben das haben wir
vor kurzem publizierte die mittlerweile
ja auch schon viel erwähnten daten aus
israel zeigen dementsprechend auch eine
nachlassende schutzwirkung und das eben
die das risiko von durchbruch infektion
wieder leicht ansteigt und es in
vereinzelten fällen auch wieder zu
schweren infektionen oder sogar zu
todesfällen kommen kann diesem
sogenannten immun raining ein phänomen
das wir gut kennen kann man aber mit
einer so genannten booster impfung sehr
effektiv entgegenwirken große studien
aus israel zeigen dass eine dritte
impfung mit einem m rna impfstoff zirka
sechs monate nach der impfung einen noch
mal um zirka 20 fach verbesserten schutz
bieten verglichen mit der zweifach
impfung das ist wirklich eine enorme
verbesserung und auch wir haben in
unseren eigenen studien beobachtet dass
die antikörper spiegel insbesondere bei
älteren menschen die er nach sechs
monaten sehr stark reduziert sind sehr
sehr stark wieder ansteigen sogar
deutlich über das niveau was jemals mit
der zweite impfung erreicht wurde das
heißt wir erwarten durch die booster
impfung nicht nur einen deutlich
verbesserten schutz jetzt im vergleich
zu dem zustand nach sechs monaten solle
möglicherweise sogar über das niveau der
zweite impfung und deswegen gehe ich
fest davon aus dass sich für die meere
nahm stoffe über kurz oder lang an drei
dosis regime etablieren wird und wir im
verlauf auch einen erwachsenen eine
booster impfung anbieten werden aktuell
empfiehlt die stiko derzeit einer ganzen
reihe von personen gruppen die booster
impfung dazu zählen vor allen dingen die
älteren menschen über 70 jahre menschen
mit schweren vorerkrankungen mit
immunschwäche und ganz wichtig
mitarbeitern im gesundheitswesen
diese menschen benötigen die wurden
zunächst die wurden auch zuerst in der
it kampagne geimpften die benötigen
jetzt eben sehr sehr dringend
angesichts der hohen infektionsrate sehr
zeitnah eine booster impfung ich habe
mir gestern mal angesehen wenn wir diese
gruppen zusammenzählen dann sind das ca
30 millionen menschen haben zurzeit
impfen wir circa 150.000 menschen am tag
das kann man sich relativ einfach
ausreichen dass wir in dem tempo diese
hoch gefährdete gruppe in diesem winter
dann nicht mehr durch impfen konnten und
wir diesen winter eben den effekt der
booster kampagne nicht mehr mitnehmen
können
deshalb plädiere ich dafür dass wir
wirklich und ersparen hat es auch gesagt
alle ressourcen nutzen um eine wirklich
koordinierte booster kampagne zu
initiieren mit der wir möglichst schnell
und rasch diese 30 millionen menschen
erreichen können aktuelle zahlen aus
israel legen zudem nahe dass eine breit
aufgesetzten muss man ja und auch das
hat esther spanier gerade gezeigt einen
deutlichen effekt auf das
infektionsgeschehen insgesamt hat das
heißt durch das gesteigerte immunität
erhalten wir auch einen dämpfenden
effekt auf die transmission des virus
und wenn sie wollen hat israel sich aus
der del tabelle effektiv raus gewusst
hat und mit blick auf die steigenden
infektionszahlen gehe ich auch davon aus
dass wir im verlauf auch in deutschland
jüngeren menschen eine booster impfung
anbieten können dass sie davon
profitieren
die stiko prüft dies aktuell auch sehr
intensiv und ich erwarte dazu auch und
ich glaube herr professor märz hat das
gestern auch angekündigt dazu in kürze
eine stellungnahme aktuell ist es aber
wichtig dass wir risiko adaptiert
vorgehen und zügig eben diese
gefährdeten personengruppen postern das
bin ich fast fertig zusammenfassend
möchte ich fort mit folgenden punkten
schließen wir sind in einer sehr
kritischen lage der pandemie die zahlen
steigen in den krankenhäusern steigt der
druck auf die betten das kann ich ihnen
aus eigener erfahrung berichten und das
personal
ist auch unter einem enormen druck und
eine trendwende ist aktuell nicht
absehbar dem können wir entgegenwirken
indem sich mehr menschen impfen lassen
die im forte ist zu niedrig auf das
mehrfach gesagt wurden regional bestehen
außerdem große unterschiede und wir
sehen das gerade im gegen niedrige
impfquote für sehr hohe
krankenhauseinweisungen haben deshalb
braucht es nochmal gezielte angebote und
auch und das wurde auch angesprochen
reglementierungen für ungeimpfte die
dann auch durchgesetzt werden die
booster impfung ist extrem effektiv sie
führt nochmals zu einer deutlich
verbesserten schutzwirkung aktuell
benötigen wir angesichts der hohen zahl
der gefährdeten wohnen und der hohen
instanzen eine koordinierte poster
kampagne unter einbeziehung aller
ressourcen inklusive der praxen der
impfzentren der mobilen teams um zügig
all diese gefährdeten gruppen zu ostern
die impfung schützt sie ist aber auch
mehr als ein eigenschutz und daher kann
ich genau wie meine vorredner nur an
alle appellieren sich jetzt impfen zu
lassen vielen dank danke auch dafür ich
erinnere an dieser stelle nochmal an
unsere regel eine frage pro person mit
der möglichkeit einer nachfrage und
bitte auch diejenigen die am anfang ihre
frage stellen sich daran zu halten und
ich beginne im saal bei frau spiekermann
kennen sie ein bisschen direkt ans mikro
sprechen dass man auch in der live
übertragung einfach rad einfach kräftige
stimme
nun ich bleibe bei dem was ich gesagt
habe es ist in den diskussionen die wir
jetzt schon öfter hatten in den letzten
wochen oder monaten und ich würde mir
auch wünschen dass wir diese
kommunikative herausforderung gemeinsam
noch etwas besser hinbekommen zwischen
dem was empfohlen ist und dem was
möglich ist also empfohlen ist durch die
ständige impfkommission auf der basis
von daten 1 kommt ja auch zur wahrheit
dazu wenn alle länder so auf daten
warten würden vor sie übers tun hätten
wir keine daten
und wir haben gesehen etwa bei den
kinder impfung mit den erfahrungen aus
den usa aus anderen ländern es hat sinn
gemacht
als die zulassung da war und die
erfahrungen aus anderen ländern früh zu
starten ich will ihn mal sagen die
zulassung für die kinder impfung für die
zwölf- bis 17-jährigen kinder
jugendliche kam am 31 mai diesen jahres
die entsprechende empfehlung der
ständigen impfkommission kam am 16
august
bis dahin war schon ein viel der
altersgruppe gottseidank geimpft
also wir konnten schon deutlich früher
menschen schützen und deswegen ist zum
einen natürlich das auswerten der daten
und dafür bin ich auch dankbar und die
arbeit der ständigen impfkommission sehr
sehr wichtig aber in einer pandemie in
der wir jetzt aktuell sind ist doch
darüber hinaus wichtig auch zu sehen
welche erfahrungen und erkenntnisse wie
aus anderen ländern haben wo vorsorglich
ein entsprechendes impfangebot eben auch
sinn macht und so haben wir es bei den
kindern und jugendlichen gemacht und ich
möchte sagen im rückblick mit viel
erfolg und so sehe ich das jetzt hier
auch wo wir die empfehlung der ständigen
impfkommission haben wie auch gut und
wichtig ist wo wir schon im august
den hinweis der
gesundheitsministerkonferenz haben den
beschluss alle über 60-jährigen ein
entsprechendes angebot zu machen und wo
wir mittlerweile eine zulassung sogar
ausdrücklich haben
für eine entsprechende booster impfung
für durch die europäische
arzneimittelbehörde für bayern tech und
moderner und insofern stellt sich jetzt
die frage eben mit dem wissen dass wir
haben dass wir zuerst einmal sowieso
derjenigen im von freddys empfohlen ist
auch da sind wir übrigens noch nicht
schnell genug zwei millionen ist weit
weg von den zahlen der professor sander
gerade genannt hat richtung 30 millionen
von denjenigen die jetzt schon auch mit
einer entsprechenden empfehlung
er beruflich bedingt oder durch
vorerkrankungen wegen des alters geimpft
werden sollten aber ich verstehe
andersrum auch nicht dass wenn menschen
in eine praxis kommen
sechs monate ist die impfung her eine
situation vielleicht haben in der sie
auch vielen anderen menschen begegnen
und sich eine auffrischimpfung wünschen
warum die dann nicht auch möglich sein
soll impfstoff ist da zulassung ist da
die erkenntnisse aus anderen ländern
sind da und insofern macht es aus meiner
sicht sind und ich möchte auch nicht
wissen sie ich bekommen berichtet das 63
jährige
die sich eine auffrischimpfung wünschen
ihnen gesagt wird
das ist nicht gut mit den erkenntnissen
die wir aus anderen ländern haben und
deswegen werde ich eben auch mit der
ärzteschaft und mit den ländern darüber
nochmal reden wie wir da das ist wichtig
möglichst einheitlich denn das ist
natürlich moment etwas verwirrend für
denjenigen der
gerade
die meldung und pressekonferenzen sich
anschaut wirklich ist einheitlich dahin
vorgehen sind ich finde vor deutlich mit
den erkenntnissen aus anderen ländern
dieses impfung wichtig
es muss schon seit anfang august schnell
gehen wir haben anfang august
vor drei monaten zwischen bund und
ländern vereinbart dass in allen
pflegeeinrichtungen es wieder mit
mobilen teams strukturierte angebote
gibt es gibt einige bundesländer in
denen ist das vollständig passiert es
gibt einige wo es nach drei monaten noch
bedarf gibt es auch gut dass der dann
jetzt angegangen wird wir haben im
august
im august
gesagt in einem folge beschluss auch die
über 60 jährigen sollen ein
entsprechendes angebot bekommen es muss
nicht jetzt schnell gehen es muss
eigentlich schon seit einigen wochen
schnell gehen der kollege kuhn vom
deutschlandfunk fragt digital an sie
gerichtet herr wieder
nach der meldepflicht für krankenhäuser
bei der hospitalisierung since it ends
fliesen patienten also wie das konkret
geregelt ist und fließen
patienten die nicht wegen krone
eingeliefert wurden sondern bei denen
die infektion nur ist neben diagnose
festgestellt wird grundsätzlich in die
statistik ein
ja das ist ein thema das wir sehr
intensiv denke ich vor einigen wochen
schon besprochen haben nochmal zum
vorgehen es gibt bestimmte gesetzliche
regelungen eine verordnung ist geregelt
worden dass die krankenhäuser personen
die korona infiziert eingeliefert werden
oder wenn sie später diagnostiziert wenn
natürlich genau so dass die
krankenhäuser diese personen melden das
ist insofern wichtig als wir darüber
etwas über die belastung der kranke
entschuldigung über die schwere der
krankheit lernen je mehr menschen im
krankenhaus
werden müssen der idee dahinter ist der
gedanke desto schwerer sind die
krankheitsverläufe also diese
hospitalisierung instanz ist ein maß für
die schwere der erkrankung und das ist
eine gesetzliche verordnung und die
krankenhäuser müssen dort melden und das
tun sie in unterschiedlichem maße wir
wissen dass es bei all diesen melde
systemen bei der so genannten c balance
immer bestimmte unter erfassungen gibt
das ist der grund warum wir ja auch seit
einigen wochen hier eine adjustierte
hospitalisierung inzidenz angeben das
hatten wir auch in einem workshop unter
anderem auch daten journalisten sehr gut
dargelegt das heißt also wir wissen dass
es eine gewisse untererfassung geht und
durch die adjustierung wollen wir das
ausdehnen
natürlich kann es sein dass eine person
nicht mit krone als diagnostiziert ins
krankenhaus kommt und dann wird sie dort
als diagnostiziert vielleicht erkannt
aber es sind natürlich viele dieser
fälle sind eben auch auf corona zurück
zu finden erzählte mal ein beispiel von
einer person die ich jetzt zufällig
selber kenne eine junge frau 21 jahre
alt kerngesund hat einen schlaganfall
und wird eingeliefert mit einem
schlaganfall und dann stellt sich heraus
dass der schlaganfall im zusammenhang
mit einer virusinfektion steht ja also
das ist nun mal die biologie und das ist
nun mal die die ganze problematik die
wir im gesundheitssystem haben sie
wissen natürlich nicht immer von
vornherein warum ein mensch eingeliefert
wird was die ursache der krankheit ist
dafür haben wir gute ärzte die das
herausfinden und wenn sie wissen dass
das dann zb durch corona virus geschehen
ist dieser schlaganfall dann wenn sie
natürlich entsprechend auch therapien
und bestimmte vorsichtsmaßnahmen treffen
also das ist gelebter alltag und gott
sei dank haben wir in deutschland viele
sehr gute ärzte die in der lage sind das
dann auch zu diagnostizieren und
entsprechend zu behandeln dann bin ich
im sauber hängt quälen
kennen auch sie direkt ins mikro
sprechen
also zuerst einmal finde ich ist die
pandemie für uns alle eine lehre seit 18
monaten immer wieder auch neue jedes
argument irgendwie der erkenntnis zu
wägen das ist es auch für mich und das
tue ich auch in dieser frage jeden tag
ich habe noch eine erfahrung aus den
letzten wochen wo wir ja
wahlkampfbedingt viel unterwegs waren in
deutschland
es ist schon ziemlich viel spannung im
land rund um das thema impfen ziemlich
viel
von ärzten die mir berichten sie dürfen
zum teil dem ehepartner des behandelten
patienten gar nicht erzählen dass der
gekämpft wurde weil er sagt ich kriege
zu hause richtig stress wenn das ein
partner erfährt er sich all diese dinge
in der familie zum teil auf arbeit an
anderen stellen und diese spannung
dürfen nicht zur spaltung führen
meine sorge bleibt
gerade mit dem auch was sich in
diskussionsveranstaltungen in den
regionen selbst erlebt habe die sehr
geringe impfquoten haben und das sind
auch die regionen wo auch beim
pflegepersonal die impfquoten geringer
es haben es angesprochen
ist meine echt große sorge dass wenn wir
eine verpflichtende impfung auch in
diesen berufsgruppen einführen dass sie
sich nicht impfen lassen sondern dass
die weg sind
also wenn 50 prozent des pflegepersonals
sagt
dann bin ich hier weg da haben wir ein
problem
und wenn die dann auch noch rausgehen
aus der debatte sozusagen und gar nicht
mehr erreichbar sind weil eine solche
verpflichtung dazu führt dass kein
gespräch mehr möglich ist sondern
verhärtung entsteht
dann ist es richtig schwierig und das
ist meine sorge ich werde die argumente
jeden tag ich sehe auch das problem es
tut mir im herzen weh ich finde es gibt
eine moralische pflicht in jedem fall
wer in diesen bereichen arbeitet sich
auch impfen zu lassen
aber für mich liegt eben diese frage was
löst das aus gesellschaftlich und bei
den einzelnen weiterhin sehr stark
kathi de
gmbh
aus dem
[Musik]
nein der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
ein bund länder gespräche auf höchster
politischer ebene verleiht erstens
einmal
auch der situation in der wir sind die
besondere vorsicht ist erfordert
nachdruck
aufmerksamkeit ich finde das ist für
sich schon ein ganz wichtiger punkt zum
zweiten sehen wir das können sie
übrigens richtig sehen dann kann man
sogar evidenz zu generieren immer dann
wenn wir einheitlich kommunizieren auch
rund um eine
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz bund und
länder entsteht viel mehr akzeptanz und
entsteht dann in einer lage mit dieser
wir haben ja schon drei wellen hinter
uns auch verhaltensänderungen und
vorsicht aus dieser botschaft heraus und
ich wir sehen es doch jetzt auch bei 2g
gibt es schon wieder sehr
unterschiedliche vorgehensweisen und ich
bleib dabei akzeptanz entsteht
nachvollziehbarkeit entsteht wenn wir
auch um zumindest in einheitlichen
rahmen haben natürlich ist die lage in
schleswig holstein mit einer inzidenz
von gut 70 eine andere als in sachsen
oder thüringen das heißt ja nicht es
braucht die gleichen maßnahmen als
braucht die gleichen parameter und ein
gemeinsames verständnis zur lage und zum
zweiten sage ich noch einmal in einer
zeit des politischen übergangs von einer
geschäftsführenden regierung auf eine
regierung die sich noch bildet in einer
pandemie die glaube ich mehr als jede
andere frage zuvor auch dass bund länder
zusammenspiel herausfordert macht es aus
meiner sicht sind eben auch diese
politische verabredung etwa zu den drei
punkten es wird er gefragt worüber
sollen wir dann reden 3g 2g 3g besser
kontrollieren kg wird auch entsprechende
regelhaftigkeit versehen test konzept
den pflegeeinrichtungen und zwar
verpflichtend und deutlich mehr als
bisher und brust an brust an ostern ich
finde das sind schon drei ziemlich
konkrete punkte über die wir uns
verständigen sollen aber doch noch mal
die konkrete nachfrage gibt es einen
einzigen schritt in die
ministerpräsidenten mit der kanzlerin
beschließen können den herr söder
kretzschmar oder herr wüst jetzt nicht
alleine gehen könnten es geht seit
beginn der bund länder gespräche in
dieser pandemie auch um ein gemeinsames
verständnis zur lage und zum weiteren
vorgehen es gibt im übrigen auch thema
man kann ein thema ein anderes thema war
ein wichtiges thema zu nehmen
krankenhausfinanzierung die
krankenhäuser sagen zu recht
wenn wir jetzt wieder anfangen betten
frei zu ziehen und planbare operationen
zu verschieden und die ersten kliniken
haben das schon tun müssen und es werden
mehr werden brauchen wir weder einen
finanziellen ausgleich und gerade die
frage von krankenhausfinanzierung ist
auch ein thema von bund länder
gesprächen also es gibt auch da
drumherum neben diesen drei punkten
punkte wo ich finde dass es sinn macht
ein gemeinsames verständnis zu haben und
wenn sie jetzt alle theoretisch können
sie natürlich bei jedem mpk beschluss
der letzten 18 monate immer sagen es
hätte da auch jeder einzelne für sich
machen können aber es geht doch hier um
kohärentes handeln in der föderalen
republik in der schwersten krise dieses
landes und vor allem jetzt eben auch um
ein gemeinsames handeln und agieren in
dieser vierten welt ich meine wenn wir
uns alle so einig sind dann kann ja der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz auch nach
einer stunde mit einem beschlussfertig
sein ich muss ja nicht zehn stunden
gehen aber es spricht hingegen sich
seine einigkeit sofern gewisse an den
eindruck von einigkeit im vorgehen hat
man jetzt nicht in jeder frage gerade
ich sag gleich mal dazu ich habe eine
frageliste mit noch über 20 offenen
fragen das werden wir nicht das werden
wir ohne aufbau schnelligkeit und
vermutlich nicht schaffen deswegen sind
weitere digitale fragen leider
vergeblich das muss ich aber schon dazu
sagen ich bin reicht ihm bei
sind die wahren
ersparen es gibt ein bisschen verwirrung
über eine angebliche äußerung der
kanzlerin gestern im cdu-vorstand vor
diesem hintergrund frage ich sie gibt es
irgendeine einigung oder
diskussionsstand in der amtierenden
bundesregierung dass man
vorschriften für ungeimpfte verschärft
und ich rede hier nicht von 2g sondern
im zweifel über lockdown ausgangssperren
kontakt sperren und das frage ich auch
sie für dem hintergrund dass die ampel
hat ein mögliche neue koalition ja auch
vor hat nicht nur denen die pandemie
notlage zu beenden sondern auch den
absatz 728 armen infektionsschutzgesetz
zu streichen wonach eben genau solche
maßnahmen landesebene zumindest in
zukunft noch möglich wären aber dann
eben durch die streichung nicht mehr
möglich wäre danke also erst einmal
kommentiere ich keine internen sitzung
und auch angebliche äußerungen selbigen
nicht grundsätzlich gilt das was
übrigens wir auch ich als bundesminister
für gesundheit über wir in der
bundesregierung seit dem sommer sagen
dass es neben drei gm chinesen getestet
als regel grundlage für herbst und
winter eben auch in regionen wo
bestimmte
infektions und intensiv zahlen sich
ergeben
gesundheitswesen überlastet zu sein
droht 2 gg im chinesen eine option sein
muss die aus unserer sicht dann auch
gezogen werden muss und das
gesundheitssystem zu schützen und das
ist die diskussion um die es dabei geht
im übrigen was in 28a
infektionsschutzgesetz angeht werden wir
wahrscheinlich heute im laufe des tages
der regierung im werden die
formulierungshilfe übersenden können
erbeten worden ist
gleichzeitig will man ihn miteinander
schauen müssen jetzt auch im weiteren
verfahren auch im gespräch mit den
ländern ob die regelungen so ausreichen
für die maßnahmen die notwendig seien
aber
nicht richtig verstanden wir reden
anders sie auch als person des
amtierenden gesundheitsminister sprechen
nicht über irgendwelche
form der weiteren beschränkung für
ungeimpfte in form von ausgangssperren
lockdown maßnahmen ähnlich ist ich weiß
ja schon sein eigentliches monaten
april/mai rechtslage ist für geimpfte
und genesene wird es keine weiteren
kontakt beschränkungen ausgangssperren
geben das ist die geltende rechtslage
der kollege zenker von der mbr fragt sie
herr bieler
ärztepräsident reinhardt hat gerade eine
form gefordert die unter anderem die
unabhängigkeit vom
bundesgesundheitsministerium vorsieht
auch in den ampel fraktion scheine es
dafür sympathien zu geben was halten sie
davon
also ich möchte sie auch sehr ungern zu
äußerungen von dritten äußern das robert
koch institut ist ja eine institution
die als teil als eine institution die im
geschäftsbereich des ministeriums ist
seine ressort
forschungsaufgabe nachkommen wir haben
in deutschland
drei säulen der forschung wir haben in
deutschland die sogenannte universitäre
forschung wir haben die
außeruniversitäre forschung da finden
sich max planck institut der helmholtz
zentren leibniz-institute
fraunhofer-institute und dann haben sie
die sogenannte ressort forschungs
forschung und die ressort
forschungsinstitutionen sind eben der
wissenschaftliche unterbau der
ministerien dahingehend berät bei
gesetzesverfahren bei bestimmten
fachthemen und das ist auch richtig und
wichtig so denn diese expertise muss ja
im gemeinsamen zusammenspiel da sein die
wissenschaft muss um hohen freiheitsgrad
gewährt werden das ist klar denn der
rahmen den wir forschen als ressort
forschen sie tut er es gesetz das gibt
es einen gesetzlichen rahmen haben
bestimmte aufgaben aber die methoden mit
denen wir diese aufgaben durchführen die
sind frei und die müssen wir müssen
entsprechend ausgestattet sein mit genug
ressourcen und diese methoden auch
wirklich durchführen zu können und das
ist der entscheidende punkt dass die
ressourcen genügt da sind die
wissenschaft muss natürlich in hohem
maße weise also mehr ressourcen als
glaube ich den letzten 18 monaten hatte
das robert-koch-institut in seine
geschichte auch nicht was mir wichtig
ist ich verstehe den punkt dahinter was
auch wissenschaftliche empfehlung und
arbeit angeht aber das
robert-koch-institut hat ja auch
operative aufgaben mit und auch stärker
denn je in dieser pandemie mit
übernommen und operative verantwortung
braucht auch immer eine politische
verantwortung insofern muss man die
frage wie man es auflöst wenn ich bei
der kollegin in der mitte
genau rebecca salwik liefern nachrichten
partei watson mir geht es jetzt mehr so
um das zwischenmenschliche und zwar
müssen wir uns denn an weihnachten
wieder sorgen machen um unsere
großeltern und wie könnte man sich
darauf vorbereiten beziehungsweise
vorkehrungen treffen
wird das entscheidende ist jetzt das
brechen dieser vierten welle
dafür sind eben erst mal unsere
individuellen
verhaltensweisen wie wir jeden tag jetzt
umgehen damit entscheidend macht den
entscheidenden unterschied das fängt
eben an bei aha regeln bei schutzmasken
in bestimmten bereichen das geht was
impfen das machten wichtigen unterschied
und wenn es um die großeltern geht vor
allem auch beim auf beschimpfen im
zweifel in der familie mitzuhelfen dass
diejenigen die in der familie besonders
verwundbar sind nämlich die älteren oder
vor erkrankte tatsächlich das angebot
zwar auffrischimpfung auch wahrnehmen
und annehmen stelle in der eigenen
familie fest das ist das wahrnehmen er
ist auch eine herausforderung
gelegentlich was dann zum annehmen führt
aber das ist eben sehr sehr wichtig wie
weihnachten oder silvester ich nehme mir
die debatte war wir haben jetzt in
seinen heute überhaupt den dritten
november ich finde wir sollten jetzt
erst mal uns damit beschäftigen die
aktuelle welle zu brechen von uns über
weihnachten gedanken machen
dann bin ich digital bei den kollegen
sascha meyer von der dpa befragten
händler oder
sander können sie erläutern warum man
mit der auffrischung des impfschutzes
sechs monate warten soll für wie viele
könnte das
für viele könnte das ja einen späten es
erst im jahr bedeuten ja
noch mal zurück gebucht wir kennen
dieses virus er seit anfang 2000 20 wir
haben die immunantwort auch erst seit
dem jahr studieren können die impfstoffe
selber sind im einsatz erst seit ende
letzten jahres das heißt also man muss
sich zunächst einmal heran tasten durch
information durch daten durch
experimente die studien live sander kann
das sicher gut noch aus dem praktischen
alltag ergänzen und sich daran tasten
und man sieht eben dass die immunität in
beobachten studie sieht man dass sie
nach lässt man kann das einerseits im
labor messen da haben wir aber noch
keine wirklich überzeugenden koreaner im
labor um zu sagen das ist ein hoher das
niedriger oder dass ein grenzwert von
bestimmten antikörpern oder t zellen
sondern haben nur nur ein hinweisen wir
machen halt beobachtungsstudien und
sehen dann in beobachtungsstudien dass
zum beispiel infektionsraten nach
gewissen monaten wieder zunehmen
und daraus ergibt sich diese frage nach
sechs monaten das zweite weise noch kurz
sagen möchte ist es gab keine grund
immunität es gibt ja immer noch keine
grund immunität das ist ein neues virus
und das heißt also dass der riesige
unterschied ja auch zur grippe wo wir
eine grundimmunisierung haben und wir
haben jetzt erstmal prinzipiell durch
eine impfung oder unglücklicherweise bei
manchen menschen auch durch eine
infektion eine immunität geschaffen und
diese immunität ist eben noch nicht so
lang anhaltend sie ist nur eine
grundimmunisierung der gewisse zeit
darum muss man sie eben auch mit postern
weiterhin das ist völlig normal ich weiß
nicht für sander wird vielleicht noch
mehr dazu sagen können was für abstände
man vielleicht denkt wir werden
selbstverständlich alle menschen auf
dauer boostern müssen um in einen guten
schutz zu geben es sei denn sie wollen
sich infizieren infizieren sich darüber
einen immunschutz aber das halten wir
für die schlechtere option ganz klar
ja also nach fünf bis sechs monaten
lässt neben der schutz deutlich nach und
wenn sie jetzt über personen reden jetzt
kürzlich erst geimpft wurden und dann
rechnerisch erst im winter dran wären da
muss man aber auch sagen die sind dann
eben noch in einer in einem zeitfenster
drin wo der schutz noch relativ gut ist
wenn es aber sechs monate her ist dann
lässt das eben nach und insbesondere bei
den älteren und da wieder der blick nach
israel sieht man dann eben auch mehr
schwere fälle oder was wir gestern
aufgehört haben aus den
pflegeeinrichtungen unter umständen auch
todesfälle deswegen ist da eben eine
besondere dringlichkeit gegeben und das
wurde ja wir sparen auch schon gesagt
hat ja schon im august kommuniziert und
deswegen ist es umso wichtiger diese
ganzen leute die im prinzip schon länger
als sechs monate jetzt
sozusagen
vergangen sind mehr als sechs monate
vergangen sind dass wir diese personen
jetzt sehr sehr zügig in der booster
impfung
wieder lebenspraktisch bekommen auch
rückmeldungen
dass jemand nicht seine booster impfung
bekommt weil es ist doch erst fünf
monate und 20 tage her also die sechs
monate sind jetzt natürlich kein gesetz
und natürlich ist es dann auch erst sehr
nassen zu sagen und ich glaube da würden
sie auch nicht widersprechen der rover
soll sander ländern der im pflegen vor
einem steht in der praxis und es sind
fünf monate und 20 oder 18 oder 23 tage
dann kann natürlich diese
auffrischimpfung gemacht werden also
dass leute uns und zwar nicht
einzelfälle sondern wirklich in einem
umfang berichten dass dann wegen eins
zwei drei wochen sind probleme an eine
auffrischimpfung zu bekommen ich glaube
das kann man verantworten dass dann auch
zu machen dazu wollte ich noch ergänzen
keine von diesen zahlen die ja von der
stiko genannt werden sind ja dogmatisch
zur hand haben die ärzte
ärztinnen und ärzte müssen ja bei allen
therapie oder impfempfehlungen
individuell abwägen und wenn natürlich
jemand kommt nach fünfeinhalb monaten
und man davon ausgeht dass hier ein
risiko besteht sich zu infizieren und
die infektionszahlen sind hoch dann
macht man natürlich ein booster impfung
das gleiche ist und das hat man auch in
israel gesehen was zählt ist das
biologische alter wenn personen also
jünger als 70 sind aber vor erkrankt
sind und man als behandelnde ärztin oder
arzt wirklich sorge haben müsste dass
sie auch schwer erkranken können dann
kann man natürlich und zugelassen ist es
ohnehin auch vorher wust an und sollte
das auch tun es geht ja jetzt mehr darum
zu sagen wo fangen wir jetzt
beispielsweise an das sind sehr viele
menschen aber man kann das machen und
individuell ohnehin und das glaube ich
kann man auch den niedergelassenen
ärzten ersten zutrauen dass sie das
risiko abwägen können und sehen konnte
besteht ein erhöhtes risiko und
natürlich machen wir es jetzt nach fünf
monaten also diese sechs monate sind ja
nirgends wo sind auch nicht für jeden
patienten gleich das ist ja auch klar
erst die frage des kollegen war weg
digital und dann bin ich im saal bei
herrn grimm der kollege war weg von rt
deutsch fragt
ich finde dass man sich ersparen zu
einem pfeiler liegt eine whistleblower
hat der renommierten medizinischen
fachzeitschrift british medical journal
massive zweifel an der zitat integrität
der daten und der sicherheit der
patienten während der zulassungsstudie
dass zwei favoritinnen stoffs geäußert
und dem fachblatt auf entsprechende
belege übergeben
unter anderem zu daten und manipulation
ist der bundesregierung und dem rk ii
vor dem hintergrund des massiven
einsatzes dieses impfstoffs in
deutschland dieses liegt bekannt und wie
gedenkt man damit umzugehen
mir persönlich ist dieses lied nicht
bekannt und insofern
manchmal werden mit fragen auch schon
was indirekt behauptet dass man dann
aber erstmal noch mal prüfen muss
insofern schlag ich einfach vor wir
informieren unsere wenn die frage dauern
noch besteht kann sich daher gerne an
die pressestelle des ministeriums sind
ja dass das league ist mir tatsächlich
seit heute morgen bekannt weil es
nämlich heute publiziert wurde im bmw in
diesem jahr es geht wenn das was drin
steht können wir natürlich momentan
nicht überprüfen das geht wohl um 1000
personen in einem zulassungsstudie also
um eine bestimmte gruppierung eine
überschaubare zahl das wird überprüft
werden das wird bestimmt untersuchungen
geben dann müssen wir aber natürlich
unabhängig von diesem lied einfach
konstatieren dass diese impfstoffe in
mehreren million milliarden bereits vor
ihm stehen und hohe wirksamkeit haben
also wir dürfen auch nicht die
relationen aus dem auge lassen dass wenn
das stimmt ist das
inakzeptabel und wird auch sicher
geahndet aber wir haben jetzt also in
deutschland berechnen wir einen schutz
vor hospitalisierung mit den in
deutschland und in der europa
zugelassenen impfstoffen von 90 prozent
im alter von 18 bis 59 jahren und von 85
prozent im alter von über 60 jahren das
sind sehr sehr wirksame impfstoffe und
es sind impfstoffe auch mit wirklich
sehr geringen nebenwirkung sie sind
sicher und das sind ja nun die real
world data die wir jetzt seit in
deutschland seit 27
dezember ansammeln und weltweit also
noch länger
dann herr grimm
ersparen ich wollte sie noch mal fragen
weil sie ja eingangs einräumten
das öffentliche eintreten für ein ende
der epidemischen notlage sei ein fehler
gewesen warum sie das getan haben die
zahlen lagen ja schon vor sie konnten
abschätzen wie sich die bälle aufbauen
würde warum haben sie es dennoch getan
herr grimm sorry aber das habe ich nicht
gesagt
dass das
fehler war dafür dass das beendet wird
ich finde wenn er das find ich jetzt
auch wichtig für die sozusagen
berichterstattung und rezeption ich habe
gesagt wenn äußerungen von mir zu hätten
verstanden werden können dass die
pandemie damit beendet ist
dann war ich nicht klar genug
also etwas anderes als das was gerade
ihre frage
aufgeworfen hat dass die rechtlichen das
habe ich doch anschließend gesagt dass
wir den rechtlichen ausnahmezustand was
das verhältnis parlament und regierung
angeht meiner sicht jedenfalls nicht
mehr brauchen
das java maßnahmen brauchen und dass wir
in einer phase sind wo wir besondere
vorsicht brauchen haben wir ihnen ja
jetzt gerade dargelegt und dass das eine
kommunikative herausforderung ist
zwischen diesem rechtszustand
und der pandemie die lage an sich das
ist das wo ich gesagt habe wenn
äußerungen die auch ich getätigt habe
den eindruck erweckt haben könnten oder
sollten
die pandemie wäre vorbei
dann hätte ich das noch klarer
formulieren müssen das war mein punkt
sie meinten jetzt also
das ist natürlich eine
anschluss gesetzgebung braucht
für die bekämpfung
der pandemie
warum ist es besser dass das jetzt auf
länder ebene geschehen muss und warum
hätte man nicht sich dafür einsetzen
können dass die
bundeseinheitliche rechtliche grundlage
verlängert werden kann die
bundeseinheitlich rechtliche grundlage
dass haben ja in dieser
bundespressekonferenz wenig alles
täuscht vor einer woche drei
vertreterinnen und vertreter der sich
bildenden regierung dargelegt wird es
geben und ich habe gerade eben schon
dargelegt dass die erbetene
formulierungshilfe für eine
entsprechende änderung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes mir
wahrscheinlich heute im laufe des tages
der sich werdenden regierungen sozusagen
und den fraktionen werden über senden
können und ich gehe davon aus stand
jetzt so ist ja die absicht dieser drei
fraktionen das ist diese
bundesgesetzliche regelung dann geben
wir haben unsere zeit eigentlich schon
überschritten bzw erreicht ich würde
gerne noch zwei fragen mitnehmen und um
kurze antworten bitten und bin beitrag
kübler
vielen dank sie haben gerade gewarnt in
sander von einer kritischen lage mit
einer und eine trendwende sei nicht
absehbar einer fanden ida ungeimpften
und in dieser pressekonferenz haben die
unter zwölfjährigen keine rolle gespielt
und meine frage an sie ist was sagen
ihnen ihre experten herr schwan gibt es
dieses risiko nicht haben sie eine neue
datenlage was ist das risiko für unter
12-jährige füllung kobelt
oder gibt es die daten noch nicht weil
sie haben ja auch gerade jenen erfolgs
von israel gezeigt und zu denen erfolg
gehört ja auch dazu dass man sich
offener gezeigt hat nicht ganz so wie
den usa gegenüber impfung der unter
zwölfjährigen
also zuerst einmal was einen impfstoff
auch für unter 12 jährigen angeht ist
jetzt in den usa das verfahren
abgeschlossen bei der europäischen
läuft es noch wir haben auch schon bei
beyond a kunz mengen gesichert für den
fall einer zulassung weil das ja auch
ein anderer anderer dosierung ist bei
diesem impfstoff dann für auch mögliche
impfung in deutschland ich kann ihnen
übrigens jetzt schon 1 vorhersagen es
wird eine zulassung wahrscheinlich geben
und dann wird es wieder eine zeit dauern
bis es eine empfehlung der ständigen
impfkommission gibt dieses zeitliche gap
zwischen dem was wir verfügbar haben als
schutzinstrument in der pandemie und der
frage ob es eine entsprechende
empfehlung ist wird sich auch dort
zeigen und die debatten die wir jetzt
mehrfach hatten werden wir auch da haben
ich will schon mal ankündigen damit sie
nicht damit niemand überrascht ist dass
das dann nochmal sich ergibt also klar
denken wir diese möglichen impfstoff mit
aber in einer ordentlichen zulassung
dass es gab eine kinder im funk denke
ich sehr sehr wichtig das zweite sind
die schutzkonzepte in kita und schule
die natürlich neben den
pflegeeinrichtungen auch das übrigens
sagen wir seit august wenn sie unser
papier nehmen von ende august
bundesministerium für gesundheit sicher
durch herbst und winter im august
haben wir für pflegeeinrichtungen und
für schulen kitas
gemeinschaftseinrichtung wo die
besonders verwundbaren sind die jüngsten
und die ältesten genau dieser schutz und
test konzepte eben auch weiter
vorgesehen und angemahnt und deswegen
braucht es die natürlich insbesondere
solange es keinen impfstoff gibt gerade
in diesem bereich auch das regelmäßige
testen was longo wird ein neuer
erkenntnisse angeht weiß ich nicht ob
sie das letzte mal möchte ich gerne mal
kontroll covi zeigen ja das haben wir ja
ich glaube seit über einem jahr auf der
website ist das dritte überarbeitete
konzept und dort stehen alle die
empfehlungen die das robert koch
institut gibt drin und zwar auf 510
settings runtergesetzt da sind natürlich
auch kitas und schulen drunter und wir
haben wir auch hier in dieser
bundespressekonferenz mehrfach
daraufhingewiesen immer wieder dass wir
bitte auch kinder nach wie vor mit
diesen schutz konzepten in schulen
schützen mit schutz und test konzepten
longo witt bei kindern das ist eine
wichtige frage die uns enorm umtreibt
natürlich auch uns im
robert-koch-institut enorm umtreibt und
wir haben letzte woche ein springt auf
den server gestellt das ist auch
entsprechend getwittert worden
das sind daten wo wir in deutschland und
mit großartiger unterstützung von
bestimmten gesetzlichen kranken- oder
das heißt unterstützen also die haben
die ganzen daten natürlich sowieso
generiert aber eben auch sehr sehr sehr
schnell überzeugend ausgewertet wo wir
einfach zeigen dass es diagnosen gibt
die mit post kurve zusammenhängen dass
die bei kindern unabhängig vom alter
eben auch definitiv häufiger vorkommen
bei solchen kindern die mit corona virus
infiziert waren als bei solchen kindern
die nicht mit corona virus infiziert
waren das sind aber retrospektive
studien beobachtungsstudien die haben
ihre limitation aber sie zeigen klar wir
haben in dieser arbeit und die ist
wirklich recht überzeugend haben man
bestimmte diagnosen die von ärzten
gestellt werden gegenüber gestellt ob
kinder und auch erwachsene
ebenso wird positiv getestet wurden oder
nicht dann hat man natürlich immer
bestimmte limitation hat die studie oder
kommt ganz klar aus dass alle
altersgruppen die bike ohne kurve
infektionen sicher nachgewiesen haben
dass bei den drei monate nach dieser
infektion
tatsächlich ein deutlich höheres risiko
besteht bestimmte krankheitssymptome zu
zeigen das heißt also wir gehen davon
aus dass es das gibt bei allen
altersgruppen wir wissen nicht wie
häufig das vorkommt nach wie vor weil
das eben auch lange beobachtet wird aber
die quintessenz ist bitte lasst uns die
kinder schützen und das credo das hören
sie von allen seit monaten es gibt auch
nichts was daran sich geändert hat der
schutz komplette gibt es seit monaten
und der die die forderung dass man
kinder die schule und kita ermöglicht
ist doch auch klar aber
da sind wir auch ziemlich klar eben mit
test strategien und schutzstrategien
kurze nachfrage und dann hat die letzte
frage herr jessen kurze nachfolger
wieder können sie das dann vielleicht
übersetzen lasst uns die erwachsenen
schützen heißt lasst uns die agenten als
lassen es die kinder schützen lassen die
kinder ja also also gut dass sie das
sagen hat habe ich verpasst so sagen
immer wir
natürlich ist auch unsere forderung dass
sich alle die im
die mit den kindern zu tun haben damit
sie auch die kinder vor infektionen
schützen diese coco strategie also alle
die kinder betreuen in kitas und schulen
natürlich zu hause sowieso werden damit
auch die kinder geschützt das muss man
ganz klar sagen weil sie reduzieren hier
die möglichkeit das virus übertragen
wird und natürlich
fordern wir auch unsere empfohlen die
kinder zu impfen das ist ja klar die
empfehlung ist ja auch schon seit
einigen monaten da selbstverständlich
sollen kinder gehen da will ich nur
sagen wir haben bundesländer in denen 60
prozent der 12 bis 17 jährigen geimpft
sind wer bundesländer da sind das 20 bis
30 prozent und natürlich macht das für
das was in den schulen und in den
familien haben wir nicht selten auch
geschwisterkinder
an risiken entstehen kann ein
unterschied
ersparen es gibt deutliche dissenz das
haben sie auch bestätigt zwischen ihrer
position und den vertretern der
ärzteschaft das trägt sicherlich nicht
zu weiteren erfolgen der impfkampagne
bei sondern zur verunsicherung was ist
ihr persönliches angebot ihr
persönlicher plan gegenüber den
ärztevertretern um diesen dissenz
möglichst in richtung gemeinsame
positionen zu bereinigen ich werde
morgen mit allen ärzteverbänden ein
gespräch führen genau über die situation
das kind auch ganz praktische themen es
gibt themen wo die frage ist wie weit im
voraus kann man welche dosen bestellen
es gibt das thema was ist wenn ich drei
oder vier nur zu impfen er habe aber
deine 6 weil anbrechen muss bis hin zu
der grundsatzfrage die sie angesprochen
haben und dazu werden wir uns morgen
austauschen und idealerweise auch
verständigen aber ansonsten bin ich
natürlich auch im regelmäßigen
informellen austausch mit vertreterinnen
und vertretern der ärzteschaft schon
seit 18 monaten nach frage wo steht
eigentlich der lka präsident
in diesem battle nenne ich jetzt mal
zwischen team spannbreite ostern und
teamspiel stiko
konzentration auf risikogruppen und
ansonsten wohnt dämonisierung
es gibt eine zulassung und die
ermöglicht diese impfungen und es gibt
eine gezielte impfempfehlung von der
stiko
das ist die lage und ich kann den
ausführungen von minister sparen nichts
hinzufügen
ich weiß
ich hab das übrigens sehe auch gar
keinen gegensatz zu erinnern mal sagen
auch persönlich sagen damit sie auch
keinen konstruieren ich sehe kein
gegensatz zu stiko ständige
impfkommission den habe ich auch bei den
kinder und jugendlichen impfung übrigens
nicht gesehen und die ständige
impfkommission gibt empfehlungen
und nach diesen empfehlungen ist es
ihnen besonders angezeigt symbolen für
bestimmte gruppen nach medizinischer
daten lage in der pandemie und
mit einem impfstoff der zugelassen ist
ein ist es was ist empfohlen das andere
ist das was möglich wir reden ja hier
über für diese impfung zugelassene
impfstoff und damit ist die impfung
möglich wenn der pandemie und das ist
auch der wortlaut aus dem beschluss der
gesundheitsminister aus dem sommer ist
die frage von vorsorglichen da bin ich
haben professor mehr und es übrigens
darüber gesprochen über diesen
unterschied zwischen einer ständigen
impfkommission empfehlung und dem
vorsorglichen aus public health
öffentlichen gesundheitsaspekten in der
pandemie sich ergebenden an impfangebot
etwa über 60-jährige über eine stiko
empfehlung hinaus wir sind da nicht im
gegensatz sondern es sind zwei
verschiedene ansätze und wenn man keinen
konstruierten an der stelle ich glaube
ich hoffe dass auch der klaren
kommunikation nach draußen vielen dank
vielen dank für viele gäste hier auf dem
podium und für alle deren fragen jetzt
nicht mehr grad kam bitte ich um
verständnis und wünsche ihnen noch einen
schönen tag